right so what can we do with this well
what i'm going to start with is by
having a look at what i know
from the negation i'm assuming to be
true so i'm going to say
assume negation is true
uh and i can see there are numerous
facts that i can pull on right for
example
i can say well k is of this uh case of
this form
four n minus one um i can say k is
composite and i can also talk about
these other pieces of information like
the known prime factors
of this these are like the building
blocks of my proof because
these are the characteristics that are
particular to this question so i'm going
to have to use them in some way right
so let's start with let's start with
this one so if it's of the form 4n minus
1
then for some value of n i can write k
in this way so i'm going to say
let k equal what letters have i got i've
used
i've used p's and q's a couple of times
there's a's and b's let's go
with um let's go with s and t so i'm
going to say
4s minus 1 is going to be my form here
and i need to say s is not just any
number
s is going to be one of these uh it's
just like n
so it has to be a positive integer okay
now
because i'm writing it in this form if
you think about what we've established
this is part c
right because if you think about what
i've established in part a and b
i know that because i'm in this form i
have to be an odd number
right because all numbers are captured
within
these two sequences that i had before so
i can say
well if i'm in this form then part a
implies for me that k
is odd now you might think well what's
the big deal with that
um what can i do with that fact well if
it's an odd number
then i can say not only is it odd but
it's composite
and there have to be only odd factors as
soon as you have a single
even factor then your resulting number
the product is
also going to be even because one of the
factors will be 2.
so therefore i can say part a tells me
that k is odd
but i also can say that it's odd and
composite so i can say that
k being composite
if i put these two facts together
i say fact these two assumptions
together that k is odd
and that k is composite that means that
k is or it can be written as is a better
way to say that
can be written as the product
of two odd numbers
remember no even numbers can squeeze
into this because as soon as you have a
single even factor
the whole number ends up being even okay
hold on a second um k can be written as
the product of two
odd numbers so i've so far used the fact
that k is composite
i've also used this fact i keep on
saying fact because i'm so used to
proving things
based on true reality based on these
assumptions the case composite
and the assumption of the form 4 n minus
1
what i haven't used is this assumption
down here that none of the factors
are of the form 4 and minus 1. so how do
i use that
well if they're not of the form 4 n
minus 1
because the factors have to be odd they
have to be the other kind of
format right we saw in part a if you got
an odd number you can either write it
as 4n minus 1 or you can write it as
4n plus 1. these are the only odd
numbers that we have
to work with but according to this
assumption
we know that none of the factors can be
of this form over here 4n
minus 1. so we can eliminate this
right that's according to our assumption
so now what i can say
is i'm going to sort of write down that
logic that i just mentioned right
none of case factors
are of the form
4n minus 1. that was just what we're
excluding right because
that is what the assumption which we
know to be false uh
actually says to us so none of case
factors are over the form four n minus
one
and this implies that the factors all
have to be
four n plus one right so i'm not going
to have enough space there so i'm going
to write it down here on the next line
i can say the factors or k's factors
k's factors
must be of the form
four n plus one okay
now this is really good because now i'm
starting to not just use part a
which you can see just here but now i
actually can invoke part b
what does part b have to do with any of
this right let's go back to it
it was you know prove that the product
of any two positive
integers of the form 4n plus 1 where n's
a positive integer that's exactly the
situation i have here
i'm saying that k has to be the product
of two odd numbers
what kind of odd number it's this kind
of odd number because i'm excluding this
other kind of odd number
i can assume that therefore it has to be
of the form 4n
plus 1 right because it's the multiple
or sorry the product
of 2 4 n plus 1 type odds right so
therefore i can say
hold on if uh if case factors must be of
the form four and plus one
then that implies that k itself
must also be of the form four n plus one
so um i guess
in fact i could write this as a
different thing i could say this is from
part b
right part b tells me that k itself
is i'm going to be a bit lazy here and
just grab this
okay so i hope you're following so far
this is how i'm bringing all the pieces
slowly together how would i say this
right well if you remember
how i did this earlier if i'm saying
that k is a composite number of this
form
4 n minus 1 i just have to pick a
particular n like
s right i mentioned before i can just
use the next letter after this because
that's why i chose s because the next
letter
is available it's unused at the moment
so i can say therefore
i cannot just let k you know look like
this
i can let k look like this
for t plus one because i'm matching this
form that you can see over here
and i just need to say you know t is one
of these positive integer things
okay but hold on a second and maybe
you're starting to see
why this is going to cause an issue and
how we're going to make the proof
actually work
stick with orange here i've got this
statement up here about what k
is that was from my assumption that was
4s minus 1.
i worked through the assumption and also
what i had in part a and part b
and i determined that i could also write
k in this format
over here so the same number apparently
i can write in two different forms
okay let's see what that leads to i can
say
let's talk about these two equations
let's give them names so i'm going to
call this one equation one
and this one equation two so i can say
equating these two equations
one and two what do i get out of that
what i'm going to have on the left-hand
side
equation one and on the right-hand side
equation
two or the right-hand sides of both
equations one and two
what do i get from this well remember
what i'm searching for is a
contradiction
i want to be able to get to some line
that clearly cannot
be true how do i do that well it has to
be based on
the properties of these numbers s and t
that i introduced whatever s and t
are they have to be positive integers
that's the only things that i know about
this so let's see if i can do some work
around here and
if you're at this point and you're like
it's not clicking for me i encourage you
to
just pause for a moment stop the video
have a think about how you would go from
here to
prove something which clearly can't be
true and that leads to the contradiction
the negation must be false
if you had to think about it or if
you're like no i just i'm ready to go i
want you to show me how to do this
here's how i'm going to go about it
right i know s and t have to be
whole numbers of some variety but i know
when i have a look at this equation
that actually this equation implies some
things about s and t
that cannot possibly be true about whole
numbers about positive integers
here's what i'm going to do i'm going to
get my pronumerals s and t
i'm going to collect them on one side so
i've subtracted 4t from both sides
and then i'm going to get the constant
terms over on the other side so in this
case i'm going to add 1
to both sides i then can just take out
this factor of four
which leaves me with this and now here's
the here's the kicker
i'm now going to divide through and make
a statement about s and t
on their own so i've got s take away t
this is the difference between s and t
it's equal to 2 divided by 4 which last
i checked
was a half now s and t remember they can
be
any positive integer you like but what i
can tell you
with great certainty is that if they are
positive integers
there are no two positive integers that
have a distance of
a half between them right like we know
the positive digits one two three four
five six seven and so on
they're either um you know zero distance
apart or one apart or two apart in other
words
they are an integer distance apart they
can't possibly
be half a unit apart this is the
contradiction that i was searching for i
can say
contradiction and the reason why is
because
s and t are positive integers so they
they can't possibly
be half a unit apart and this is what i
wanted i've got a contradiction of a
ride there i can say
since the negation is false that means
because a negation always has the
opposite truth value
to the statement where it came from the
original statement
i can say the original implication
in this context the original implication
must be true and
that's the end of my proof by
contradiction so
i hope that made sense to you i know
it's it's quite weird to follow what's
going on here it's quite different
in terms of the way you deduce and make
progress
through a proof like this but i would
compare it to the very first time
you learned how to deal with you know
trigonometric identities right
you have a series of ideas and how to
connect them logically together when you
began they were quite unfamiliar
and weird to play with but as you get a
little more practice in and become more
comfortable with these ideas
and concepts you'll see that the
building blocks that we've seen
of you know suggesting ideas being able
to negate use contrapositives and that
kind of thing
they can actually be combined together
in some really interesting ways that i
hope will make sense to you
and will enable you to prove the results
that you're asked for